which quadratic has the lowest maximum
value so let's figure out the maximum
value for each of these and they're
defined in different ways and then see
which one is the lowest and I'll start
with the easiest so H of X we can just
graphically look at it visually look at
it and say what's the maximum point and
the maximum point looks like it's right
over here when X is equal to 4 and when
X is equal to 4 y or H of X is equal to
negative 1 so the maximum for H of X
looks like it is negative 1 now what's
the maximum for G of X and they've given
us some points here and here once again
we can just eyeball it and say well
what's the maximum value they gave us
well 5 is the largest value it happens
when X is equal to 0 G of 0 is 5 so the
maximum value here is 5 now f of X they
just give us an expression to define it
and so it's gonna take a little bit of
work to figure out what the maximum
value is the easiest way to do that for
a quadratic is to complete the square
and so let's do it
so we have f of X is equal to negative x
squared plus 6x minus 1 I never like
having this negative here so I'm going
to factor it out this is the same thing
as negative times x squared minus 6x and
plus 1 and I'm going to write the plus 1
out here because I'm fixing to complete
the square now just as a review of
completing the square we essentially
want to add and subtract the same number
so that part of this expression is a is
a perfect square and to figure out what
number we want to add and subtract we
look at the coefficient on the x-term
it's a negative 6 you take half of that
that's negative 3 and you square it
negative 3 squared is 9 now we can't
just add a 9 that would change the
actual value of the expression we have
to add a 9 and subtract a 9 and you
might say well why are we adding and
subtracting the same thing if it doesn't
change the value of the expression and
the whole point is so that we can get
this first part of the expression to
represent a perfect square this x
squared minus 6x plus 9 is X minus 3
squared so I can rewrite that part as X
minus 3 squared
and then not minus 9 or negative 9 plus
1 is is negative 8 so - let me do that
in a different color so we can keep
track of things so this part right over
here is negative 8 and we still have the
negative out front still have the
negative out front and so we can rewrite
this as if we distribute the negative
sign negative X minus 3 squared plus 8
now let's think about what the maximum
value is and to understand the maximum
value we have to interpret this negative
X minus 3 squared well X minus 3 squared
before we thinking about before we think
about the negative that is always going
to be a positive value but then when we
make it negative or it's always going to
be non-negative but then when we make it
negative it's always going to be non
positive think about it if X is equal to
3 this thing is going to be 0 and you
take the negative of that it's going to
be 0 X is anything else X is anything
other than 3 this part of the expression
is going to be positive but then you
have a minus sign so you're going to
subtract that positive value from 8 so
this actually has a maximum value when
this term when this first term right
over here when this first term right
over here is 0 the only thing that this
this part of the expression can do is
subtract from the 8 so you want this if
you want to get a maximum value this
should be equal to 0 this equals 0 when
X is equal to 3 when X is equal to 3
this is 0 and our function hits its
maximum value of 8 so this has a max do
that in a color that you can actually
read this has a VC max value of 8 so
which has the lowest maximum value H of
X